is there anything that isn't going up
shopping food energy fuel even a ticket
to ride
[Music]
gas and electric have really gone up
even bread and milk every day's juice
things that every time you go
they've gone up 10 pence every day
you're going and it's a different price
you know
it was 40 years ago that newcastle got
its metro system when it opened at the
start of the 1980s people were used to
double-digit inflation
how many times did you go off in a day
three times in a day did you ever got
left
at him that day
[Laughter]
pamela isn't throwing plates again
well not yet
i think for your ones
with children and mortgages and
the cost of getting to work and you're
driving and
it's everything it's scary
but the reason for being here is that
the northeast now has some of the
highest levels of child poverty in the
country coupled with some of the lowest
weekly wages it's here that double-digit
inflation
really hits home
biker is one of the most deprived
neighborhoods in the north
summer activity clubs that are laid on
for free
are gratefully received the demand has
gone up through the roof it's a ticking
time bomb because that will
when the penny really crunches in which
it has done and it's going to get worse
that will impact on everyone around
people will have nothing so what they're
going to do and now you know your crime
is going to rise you can have
anti-social behavior you're going to
have more
like dividing communities 3 4 5
6. the grind of inequality is of course
nothing new covid made things worse and
for some inflation
is just another crisis
do you see people helping each other
more now
from what i see from my kind of side
yeah definitely i mean to be honest so
now and then i might want an onion and i
don't have i will run to my next door or
salt to things like this which is good
you know because
it's hard togetherness helps but
double-digit inflation has real
consequences
particularly for those who can least
afford them
tom parmenter sky news newcastle